we're gonna leave you with uh our last
song it's one of the first songs that we
wrote at your house that's right when
your brother was still around yeah my
brother Mark we rehearsed a lot of the
first record and wrote we wrote a lot of
different places but the record was like
rehearsed and tidied up real strong as a
tight band at that house but I remember
we were feeding my snake
Bobo and you were writing lyrics that
day about pets I mean yeah we're just
looking at the world thinking like how
dumb human beings can be sometimes you
know you start thinking to yourself well
if we were ever taken over by let's say
martians or another civilization that
would be an intelligent
civilization I don't know we might make
good
[Music]
pets
children are
innocent
teenagers [__] up in the head adults
are even more [__] up and elderly
like
[Music]
children will it be another race to come
along and take over for us maybe Ms
could do better than we done we'll make
great BS we'll make great BS make great
BS we'll make great bets make great BS
we'll make great bets make great BS you
make great
[Music]
BS and my friends says we're like
dinosaurs only we are we're doing
ourselves in much faster than
L ever de make great PS we'll make great
PS we'll make great PS we'll make great
PS make great FS we'll make great
FS baby it will make great
[Music]
B Make Way FS we make
way we'll make great FS make great FS
we'll make great
PS your baby will make great
[Music]
PS